soy tibia luego de la matanza más de
tres millones de habitantes
y había activos los cuales sus tres más
importantes hasta por más del 70 del 80
mi padre toti flores junto a mi madre
tenía de pueblo del interior
tenían a mejorar su calidad de vida y a
través del trabajo lo lograban porque la
matanza había sido una zona industrial
muy importante pero a partir de la
crisis desocupación en la década del 90
su vida dejó de tener sentido y
empezaron a crecer las villas nuestros
asentamientos mucha gente que venía al
pueblo del interior para mejorar su
calidad de vida y no había trabajo sería
ahí un proceso muy difícil durante toda
mi adolescencia que fue generando un
montón de conflictos conflictos
personales familiares
la falta de trabajo generando solar la
la carencia de cuestiones económicas
crea la carencia de perspectiva de
sueños de energías desgastadas en cosas
que por ahí
terminan siendo violencia también siendo
bronca enojo resentimiento
en la de que el 90 en el año 95 mi padre
empieza a constituir el movimiento de
trabajadores desocupados para poder
visibilizar el problema que teníamos de
la enorme cantidad de personas que se
están quedando por fuera del mercado
laboral yo tenía sólo 15 años tenía
muchos problemas de conducta como la
mayoría de los adolescentes pero estaban
a punto de echarme de la escuela mi
madre no sabía qué hacer conmigo me dijo
anda con tu papá a ver si te dé una mano
porque ya no sé qué hacer con vos y me
acerqué a la organización un movimiento
de trabajadores desocupados que no sabía
muy bien de qué se trataba pero que me
parecía interesante era un espacio que
la contenía que no ayudaba que sobre
todo me permitía decir el enojo que
tenía por todas las cosas que me venían
pasando pero que ese enojo también voy a
canalizar generando cuestiones más
positivas entonces me decían estás
contra el sistema bueno generaba una
acción una acción contra el sistema en
serio y entonces brindaba apoyo escolar
y le enseñaba a leer y escribir a los
chicos del barrio y empezaba a generar
acciones que canalizaban mi rebeldía
haciendo cuestiones de un poco más
positivas que andar peleando mejor por
ahí por la vida
el movimiento de trabajadores
desocupados mtd la matanza en el año 97
rechazan los planes asistenciales que
era la única respuesta que daba el
estado el gobierno en ese entonces y
decidimos constituir nuestra propia
cooperativa una cooperativa y
encontramos en el cooperativismo una
herramienta de transformación
encontramos tener cooperativismo esos
valores esos principios que generaban
cambios cambios importantes en una
comunidad que se denomina marginal que
todavía está al margen que no tiene
cloacas que no tiene a falsos creo que
tiene un montón de gente con ganas de
salir adelante en el año 2001 iniciamos
el proceso de construcción de esta
cooperativa los últimos más de 20 veces
vamos a ver gestionar administrar vender
pero toda esta vez es que nos fundíamos
no teníamos alternativa era o levantando
o aceptar el plan a irnos a nuestra casa
así que no había otra cosa otra
posibilidad y como somos rebelde y
cabeza dura decidimos seguir allá por el
año 2004 vimos nuestro propio jardín
porque decíamos la educación y en
trabajar en las dos herramientas que nos
iban a sacar adelante y que van a
generar que nuestra comunidad mejore su
calidad de vida
así que empezamos con un jardín luego
fuimos a proyectos productivos nuestra
panadería conocida por el pan dulce que
hacemos con maru botana y que nos dimos
cuenta con margot danés de importancia
que tenía en la construcción con otros
sectores de la sociedad que nosotros
solos en la juanita podíamos soñar un
montón pero que era muy difícil
concretar los sueños si no lo hacíamos
con otros si nos soñábamos a lo grande y
con otros que muchas veces son distintos
a nosotros porque tienen el mismo
objetivo de construir un mundo de que
todos tengamos un lugar así que hicimos
el pan dulce el famoso pan dulce de la
dignidad le llamamos el pan dulce con la
receta de maru botana producido en la
cooperativa de las manitas cuando es de
primerísima calidad que tiene packaging
con diseños exclusivos al principio le
llamó su envoltorio bueno no sabíamos
muy bien ni siquiera sacarle el costo
pero pan dulce primerísima calidad que
nos compran empresas importantísimas del
país y del mundo el nombre de margot a
la nos abre las puertas para que para
ella cualquier empresa y vender nuestro
producto que tiene una particularidad no
vendemos un pan dulce de primera calidad
contamos una historia una experiencia
que hacemos con cada pan dulce que
vendemos le salvamos la vida a alguien
le damos una manera y el educamos a
quien generamos las condiciones para
poder vivir mejor en nuestra comunidad y
hoy en un montón de otras comunidades en
el país así que decimos 'nuestro conduce
como vehículo de integración como
herramienta que nos permite demostrar
que la integración social es posible
pero así como con el pan dulce que no
estamos vendiendo por supuesto a
fernando cuenta con martín churba y la
exportación de guardapolvos a japón con
juan josé campanela y el armado una
escuela de oficio en nuestro potrero
digital oficios digitales en nuestro
barrio que antes pensábamos que el que
trabajaba con una computadora era un
vago que nos trabajaba de hecho me lo
decía mi mamá a poner a trabajar y dejar
esa computadora hoy sabemos que no
podemos hacer en un barrio marginal no
podemos trabajar con una computadora en
nuestra casa hoy sabemos que esa cultura
que nos habían impuesto no era así como
nos habían querido comenzar que por ser
pobres tenéis que solamente hacer
oficios manuales hoy le puedo decir
tenemos chicos nuestra comunidad
trabajando en las empresas
multinacionales más importantes y
trabajando para afuera hablando inglés y
son de nuestro barrio de nuestra
comunidad a través de los oficios
digitales que se enseñan en la comunidad
lo pensamos en la juanita y hoy se está
replicando prácticamente en todo el país
pero sobre todo en los barrios como la
31 y en barrios que no tienen
posibilidades de acceso a la tecnología
ahí vamos con capacitación y con
proyectos y perspectivas en la cual éste
encuentra un espacio que me contuvo en
la juanita encontró un espacio en el que
aprendí a soñar y a concretar mis sueños
en la juanita ha aprendido que podemos
transitar nuestros propios prejuicios
para recorrer este camino con nosotros
que muchas veces son muy distintos a
nosotros decimos que tiene que ver más
botanas juan josé campanela con la
cuenta tenemos mucho más en común aunque
vivamos en lugares totalmente distintos
aunque tengamos necesidades totalmente
diferentes
y sabemos que un país distinto un mundo
diferente lo construimos entre todos y
que si no nos juntamos en lo que nos une
vamos a seguir viviendo como vivimos
y me importa donde te haya tocado al
azar todos podemos hacer algo para
construir un mundo en el que todos
tengamos un lugar así que si en la cual
estás lo pudimos hacer estoy segura que
se puede hacer en todo el mundo así que
será bienvenido a seguir encontrándonos
en este camino muchas gracias
[Aplausos]